un new deal pour la santé pour le
prochain quinquennat c'est l'appel de la
fédération hospitalière de france le
président de la fhf réclame un plan
massif dans gauche et l'accès aux soins
pour tous et à toute heure la
déclaration fait suite à la guerre des
chiffres sur la fermeture des lits dans
les hôpitaux le président du conseil
scientifique parler de 20% de lits
fermés un chiffre démenti par l'exécutif
après vérification la réalité tournerait
autour de 6% en moyenne explication
estelle farges
6% c'est le pourcentage de lit qui
seraient fermés à l'hôpital public
estimations de la fédération
hospitalière de france la fhf dans les
colonnes du jdd la tension est là mais
elle est beaucoup moins catastrophique
que ne l'avait estimé le conseil
scientifique début octobre cette
nouvelle estimation se fonde sur une
étude de la fhf le journal du dimanche
explique que dans 70 % des cas ces
fermetures de lits sont dus à un manque
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants sans
compter les nouvelles normes sanitaires
apparu avec le co vite qui ont contraint
les établissements à fermer des lits
supplémentaires
c'est cohérent avec les résultats de l
enquête sur les ressources humaines dans
les hôpitaux que nous avons publié fin
août sur 350 établissements 4 5 % des
postes d'infirmiers était vacant
l'obligation de ne mettre qu'un malade
par chambre pour éviter la propagation
du virus est responsable de 24% des
fermetures actuelle la situation globale
est plus difficile qu'avant la pandémie
estime la fédération hospitalière de
france et elle pourrait s'aggraver car
la pression sur le personnel soignant
est toujours plus forte le président de
la fhf redoutent la perte de 4000
médecins généralistes sur les quatre
prochaines années si les mesures prises
lors du ségur de la santé et l'injection
de fonds publics ont permis de maintenir
le paquebot à flot il estime cependant
que ce n'est pas suffisant et réclame je
cite un new deal de la santé va-t-on
continuer à avoir la fréquentation de
ces urgences augmenté de 10% par an à
être le premier recours avant la
médecine de ville et la principale cible
des économies en matière de santé le
système inventé il ya 30 ans prend l'eau
il doit être repensé au ministère de la
santé on a commandé une étude la plus
exhaustive possible
au sujet des fermetures de lits dans les
hôpitaux olivier vers en lui même se
rendra d'ailleurs au salon annuel de la
fédération hospitalière de france ce
mardi 8 novembre pendant ce temps la
situation dans les hôpitaux restent
tendues et cela pourrait encore durer
ces prochaines semaines si l'on en croit
le ministère de la santé